sans faire attention que tout en dépend
c'est l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous s'il
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 11 février
[Musique]
chaque semaine gagne est une semaine de
respiration insiste olivier ferrand lors
du point hebdomadaire sur la situation
sanitaire les variants progresse le
britannique représenterait 25% des cas
le brésilien et sud-africains 4 à 5%
le ministre de la santé qui assure que
tout sera fait pour éviter un nouveau
confinement une gestion de la crise
sanitaire parfois dénoncer c'est le cas
de clara bouaziz qui souhaite que
justice soit rendue après le décès de
son père le 6 avril dernier
nous entendrons son témoignage dans
quelques instants
aux etats unis troisième jour de procès
en destitution pour donald trump jugé au
sénat pour incitation à l'insurrection
dans l'assaut meurtrier sur le capitole
au lendemain de la diffusion des matches
auxquels les procureurs démocrates vont
poursuivre à charge leur exploser de son
côté joe biden s'est entretenu au
téléphone avec sin jean ping le
président chinois qu'il veut tenir tête
[Musique]
paris appelle l'iran à prendre aucune
mesure qui aggraveraient la situation la
république islamique qui a entamé à la
production d'uranium métal pour s'en
servir comme combustible pour un de ces
réacteurs ce qui constitue une nouvelle
violation de ses engagements de la corde
2015 comme le précise l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
[Musique]
olivier ferrand donc pris la parole tout
à l'heure lors du fameux point
hebdomadaire sur la situation sanitaire
le ministre de la santé qui se félicite
de chaque jour gagner sans être confinés
dans cette bataille contre le coc vide
pour plus de précisions retrouvant en
dire avec nadège abderrazak de l'avenue
de ségur bonsoir nadège alors que
peut-on retenir de cette prise de parole
[Musique]
écoutée stéphanie olivier ferrand très
inquiet de la poussée des différents
variant britannique sud africain et
brésilien des variants que le ministre
de la santé estime up dangereux et plus
contagieux alors en ce qui concerne le
variant britannique
il a été repéré dans 20 à 25% des cas de
contamination au quotidien au co vide
le vaccin serait très efficace des
titans olivier ferrand contre eux ce
variant en revanche le doute persistant
sur les variants sud africain et
brésilien qui pour leur part ont été
repérés dans 4 à 5% à des cas de
contamination des variants qui
augmenterait les risques de réinfection
chez les patients déjà contaminé aux
copies de 19
olivier ferrand c'est aussi lors de
cette conférence de presse dit satisfait
de la stratégie française de lutte
contre la propagation du virus stratégie
en opposition avec celle de nos voisins
européens notamment au sujet du
confinement
nos voisins ont confiné parce qu'il
n'avait plus le choix
l'allemagne et l'angleterre ont connu
des journées avec plus de 1500 morts par
jour et donc il n'avait pas d'autre
alternative que celle d'un confinement
généralisée parce qu'il risquait une
saturation de leurs hôpitaux
c'est le cas aussi aux pays bas en
irlande en autriche et dans de nombreux
pays et nadège olivier ferrand qui s'est
toutefois inquiétée de la situation en
moselle où les cas de contamination sont
en hausse
absolument dans ce territoire du grand
est et près de 300 cas de contamination
aux variants brésilien et sud africains
ont été diagnostiqués au cours des
quatre derniers jours
la situation est tellement inquiétante
que le ministre de la santé a décidé de
se déplacer demain en moselle la
situation est un peu différente dans un
département du territoire c'est la
moselle c'est une situation plus
inquiétante
nous avons identifié dans ce département
plus de 300 cas de mutation évocatrice
des variants sud africain et brésilien
ces quatre derniers jours je me rendrai
demain en moselle pour évaluer sur place
la situation et échanger avec les élus
du territoire
j mènerait une concertation afin
d'anticiper les réponses qu'il nous
faudra trouver collectivement et un peu
plus tôt dans la journée olivier verront
s'est rendu dans une école du xiiie
arrondissement de paris avec jean castex
le premier ministre à nadège
et le butin de cette visite dans cette
école c'est d'y déployer une nouvelle
arme contre la propagation du cosby de
19 le test salivaire une technique moins
douloureuse que le prélèvement nasal
puisqu'il consiste un prélèvement dans
la bouche ou un prélèvement parts rachat
à la rentrée des vacances cet hiver
le gouvernement espère ainsi que 200 à
300 milles et tests salivaires seront
effectués chaque semaine dans les écoles
ces tests salivaires évidemment chacun a
connu le test naso pharyngé et ses
inconvénients
le test salivaire évidemment beaucoup
plus facile d'accès il permet là aussi
d'avoir des résultats dans des délais
rapides 24 heures puisque c'est la
technique pcr pour être extrêmement
précis et donc nous avons décidé de le
déployer d'abord on le comprend bien en
direction des enfants dans les écoles
dans les collèges dans les lycées parce
qu'évidemment c'est un public qui est
plus fragile et qui est parfois plus
réticents aux tests naso pharyngé et aux
désagréments qu'il peut provoquer ce
dans une école parisienne auquel n'a pas
participé à laquelle n'a pas participé
jean michel blanc coeur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a été retenu à
l'assemblée nationale où les débats sur
le projet de loi séparatisme se sont
poursuivies ce jeudi encore merci nadège
abderrazak en direct de l'avenue de
ségur et l'état face au co vide depuis
presque un an maintenant certains points
de sa mauvaise gestion c'est le cas de
clara bouaziz qui souhaite que justice
soit rendue après le décès de son père
le 6 avril dernier
deux plaintes ont été déposées dont
l'une contre eux edouard philippe agnès
buzyn et olivier verrons avec cette
procédure pénale clara et son avocat
maître division accuse l'état d'
homicide involontaire et d'abstention
d'abstention volontaire de prise de
mesures propres à combattre l'épidémie
nous sommes en dire
que tu avec l'arabe oasis pour
recueillir son témoignage
mais bon soir clara bouaziz merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rtl france votre
père un épisode aurait donc décédé au
mois d'avril des suites du coc vide en
coin estimez-vous que l'état est
responsable
alors j'estime que l'état est
responsable parce que mon père n'a pas
été protégé d'une part il n'a même pas
été prévenus
informé de la présence de cette épidémie
qui a commencé quand même relativement
tôt il n'a pas eu de masques il n'a pas
eu de test
il n'a y n'a rien eu j'ai fait
énormément de pharmacie pour trouver de
quoi les protéger pas de masque pas de
thèse pas de gants pas de gel même pas
d'alcool à 60° rien du tout donc ils se
sont retrouvés seuls
et mes parents se sont confinés on a
supposé qu'ils avaient locaux vides et
il y avait un petit message qui passait
à la télévision moi j'ai trouvé ce
message assez mortifère on le disait que
comment dire si on avait un peu de
températures un peu de fièvre
effectivement on était malade et on
proposait donc aux patients de rester
confinés chez eux de s'infecter entre
eux et ma foi et d'attendre que ça passe
au bout de quelques jours
si malheureusement ça ne passait pas il
fallait éventuellement appelé un médecin
ou appeler le samu quand on avait des
difficultés respiratoires
sauf que quand on appelle le samu et que
l'on a des difficultés respiratoires
il est quasiment trop tard comment ce
plu oui oui
pardonnez moi oui je vous laisse
poursuivre je pensais que vous aviez
terminé mais ma question suivante que
vous allez vous allez y répondent
évidemment en terminant votre propos
c'était comment justement s'est passée
sa prise en charge la prise en charge de
votre papa au niveau hospitalier je vous
laisse se terminer votre récit bien
évidemment oui alors mon récit c'était
ce que je voulais je voulais
insister sur le fait aussi qu'il avait
été qu'ils avaient été confinés très
tardivement c'est à dire que chaque jour
je me demandais quand on allait recevoir
ce message un petit peu gouvernementale
pour nous prévenir du confinement pour
que nous soyons au moins très protégé en
attendant de nous organiser et en fait
il a fallu attendre le passage des
élections vous savez municipal c'est à
dire que un jour avant les élections ont
été libres on se baladait dans les rues
comme si de rien n'était alors que
microbes virus était là l'épidémie était
là et un jour après les élections
c'était la guerre on était entré en
confinement donc vous savez c'était une
limite très très ténu qui qui qui est
qui dépend des de ces élections est
malheureusement ces élections retardées
le confinement bon comment s'est ensuite
justement j'en reviens à ma question
passer sa prise en charge
oui alors la prise en charge a été assez
difficile oui je n'ai pas on n'a pas pu
faire de test je dois insister sur le
fait que je gérais dans les rues de
paris
j'appelais tous les labos et je les
suppliais de venir faire des tests pour
mes parents mais quand je vous dis
suppliait je pleurais dans la rue je
demandai je disais je vous supplie je
vous en supplie venez faire des tests à
ma famille ils sont tous malades il faut
les prendre en charge et les labos me
répondez nous n'avons pas d'agrément
nous n'avons pas d'agrément j'ai même
appelé les labos comment dire
vétérinaire en les suppliant également
devenir mais rien n'y a fait c'est à
dire qu'on n'avait pas l'agrément
c'était impossible sauf que sauf que
j'ai déposé une plainte à la cour de
justice de la république et en cherchant
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
énormément de mines
deux députés et cetera qui au mois de
mars avait réussi à se faire tester
pendant que moi j'ai ré dans les rues
pendant que je pleurais pour mes parents
se faisait testées se faisait
hospitalisés et les parents n'ont pas eu
droit ça c'est à dire deux poids deux
mesures
c'est à dire que la vie de mon père au
jour d'aujourd'hui s'il avait eu le même
le le même sort que ces personnes mon
père serait vivant à côté de moi mais là
donc nous n'avons pas eu droit au test
contrairement à la prise en charge a
donné moi c'est ton ministre que vous en
voulez pas ce que vous tentez clairement
où plein contrôle et minsk ont assité
tout à l'heure c'est à eux que vous en
voulez ou c'est au système qu'ils
incarnent
alors j'en veux j'en veux aux ministres
bien évidemment ils sont les
superviseurs du système je suis désolé
dans ce système on a des fonctionnaires
on a des personnes qui travaillent mais
nous avons monsieur edouard philippe qui
est le superviseur numéro un
madame agnès buzyn qui est le
superviseur de la santé et puis après
nous avons jérôme salomon les
fonctionnaires etc
il ya tout un tout un ensemble qui qui
marchent de pair donc bien évidemment
j'en veux aux ministres aujourd'hui
c'est un combat judiciaire qui commence
pour vous qu'est ce que vous en attendez
le la reconnaissance du statut de
victime tout simplement tout cas pour
votre papa
j'en attends le statut de victime mais
je veux des responsables il y à des
responsables mon père était en
excellente santé
il était dans la vie mon père c'est
quelqu'un qui allait à la piscine avant
avant le que vit tous les jours c'est
quelqu'un qui faisait ses courses qui
cuisinait qui nous faisait des
confitures qui faisait de la peinture
pour tous ces petits enfants chacun un
tableau tous les jeudis recevait le
dernier nouveau né de la famille s'en
occuper avec ma mère nous étions en
train de préparer un voyage à l'étranger
au maroc où ils voulaient nous nous nous
amener sur les traces de son enfance et
cetera
donc il n'avait aucune raison
de de tomber malade et de mourir
aucune il n'a pas été protégé pas de
masque rien du tout c'est quelque chose
d'inconcevable je dois dire quand agnès
buzyn a prévenu en janvier
monsieur macro et la prévenue edouard
philippe elle a prévenu jérôme salomon
eux étaient prévenus nous nous étions
pas prévenu du danger mais prévention
égale prévenir prévenir égale prévention
c'est la moindre des choses on l'a fait
on a on comment dire on a méprisé la vie
des français on a méprisé la vie des
citoyens
c'est inacceptable les masques n'était
pas nécessaire mais depuis quand les
masques qu'ils ne sont pas nécessaires
lors d'une épidémie
je veux dire c'est une question de bon
sens une femme qui accouche si on veut
la visite et si on veut la voir et que
vous êtes enrhumé il y à une infirmière
qui n'aura pas fait polytechnique ni
sciences po qui va vous dire s'il vous
plaît mettez un masque pendant la pause
et il faut bien il faut bien rappeler à
l'époque justement c'est peut-être là
que le bât blesse et qu'il n'y avait
tout simplement pas de deux matchs
est-ce que vous pensez que ces ministres
ont menti sciemment justement où il ya
eu de la négligence il ya eu selon vous
du mensonge tout simplement ou un
scandale d'état d'ailleurs c'est c'est
un très grand mensonge et qui plus est
c'est une irresponsabilité parce que
tout simplement on envoyait 17 tonnes de
matériel médical en chine dans ses 17
tonnes il y avait des combinaisons il y
avait des masques il y avait des gants
il y avait du gel en retour la chine
nous a envoyé un million de masques pour
nous aider donc on s'est dénudée pour la
chine c'est une chose auquel nous
n'avons plus rien mais s'il vous plaît
on peut on a affaire à un pays où les
les citoyens sont sont intelligents nous
n'avons pas de masque tout simplement
tout simplement
et bien on fait appel à la force vive du
pays et on retrouve nos manches
on demande à toutes les femmes qui
savent coudre de faire des masques moi
j'ai une copine qui a fait une centaine
de masques on prévient on il ya des
retouches heures il ya des usines de
tissus toutes les femmes qui ont des
machines à coudre peuvent faire des
mains
on n'est pas bête on comprend les choses
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs les français se
sont mis à faire des masques ils n'ont
plus attendus attendre quoi il n'y avait
rien donc ils se sont mis à faire des
maths mais on nous on aurait pu nous le
dire dès le début c'est comme les usines
on aurait pu dû réquisitionner les
usines par exemple de plexiglas comment
expliquez-vous que au mois de mai alors
là le plexiglas est apparue de tous les
côtés on a protégé les taxis on a
protégé les banques ont à protéger les
caisses
on a pu me d'aidés plastique mais on
pouvait pas le faire avant on pouvait
pas réquisitionnés
combien de chauffeurs de taxi sont morts
sa voisine pardonnez moi c'était le tout
début de la crise malheureusement le
virus était moins connu qu'aujourd'hui
est ce que vous estimez qu'à ce jour la
stratégie du gouvernement s'est
améliorée oui ou non notamment sur les
vaccins par exemple écouter sur les
vaccins vous trouvez que c'est très
positive où il est trouvée actif je
voulais trouver dynamique vous trouvez
que ça bouge
moi je connais une vieille dame de 88
ans on lui a proposé d'aller faire son
vaccin à lille est ce que c'est normal
elle habite paris elle a pas encore fait
c'est pas normal
mon et puis qui plus est on vous ton
vous dont on vous demande de vous
connecter sur internet
à chaque fois on vous demande de
connecter sur internet mais vous
imaginez vous des personnes de 80 de 88
ans 90 ans se connecter sur internet
c'est en dépit du bon sens c'est comme
si on envoyait du riz en afrique où il
n'y a pas d'eau quoi je veux dire les
personnes âgées on les prend en charge
réellement
merci en tout cas clara bouaziz de nous
avoir apporté votre témoignage en direct
sur rt france merci souligné quelque
chose
bien sûr j'ai deux minutes en plus
allez-y oui mon père était oui oui mon
père a été
à l'hôpital où on a cru qu'il serait
prise en charge est en fait il n'a pas
il n'a pas été soignée il n'a pas reçu
de perfusions d'antibiotiques et il
s'avère qu'avec sa dépression
respiratoire trois jours après son
arrivée
on lui a donné une injection
d'anxiolytiques et de morphiniques donc
ce qui l'a terrassé 4 jours plus tard il
est décédé quelques jours plus tard on
ne donne pas de morphiniques on ne donne
pas d'anxiolytiques à quelqu'un qui a
une dépression respiratoire donc là
encore je suis dans l'obligation de de
déposer une plainte contre l'hôpital et
le médecin qui a pris cette décision
inacceptable et et infâme
merci en tout cas que l'arabe oasis
d'avoir été avec nous et merci pour
votre témoignage et si l'état est pointé
du doigt pour sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire on vient de l'entente n'est
peut-être fautif c'est à la justice de
trancher l'état n'est-il pas surtout
malade de son propre système et de sa
lourdeur administrative l'état en l'état
est il finalement à même d'être réactif
et efficace face à cette crise sanitaire
inédite c'est l'objet de notre face à
face
[Musique]
pour en débattre rémy rebeyrotte débuté
la république heures marche troisième
circonscription de saône-et-loire bonsoy
rémy rebeyrotte merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés alain houpert sénateur les
républicains en de la côte d'or
bonsoir à tous les deux on a entendu ce
témoignage plein de tristesse et de
passion évidemment de notre invité qui
dénonce en substance une forme de
scandale humanitaire vous trouvez que
c'est un jugement sévère rémy rebeyrotte
que vous ont inspiré ses propos elle
pointe clairement du doigt la
responsabilité de l'état et des
ministres
oui je veux simplement dire on n'y
peuvent pas offert de lui il s'est passé
à l'époque je veux bien sûr adressés à
cette personne
toutes mes condoléances sa sympathie aux
matches et personne d'ailleurs sont
décidés à vis des familles y sont passés
par ces épreuves
ries lui banc et il s'en doute des
simples agents monsieur à la terre
entière parce que on a découvert la
maladie rappelle qu'à l'époque on
parlait de pour le retenir
au bilan la solution universelle il ya
eu beaucoup pas tellement les pauvres
eux on s'est surpris si naturellement à
vous donner
c'était très compliqué comme situation
mais j'allais dire moi je voudrais pas
me rend vraiment hommage aux oignons ils
ont fait le maximum même si même si
évidemment cette situation était
extrêmement et douloureuse c'est vrai
quel point surtout l'état et les
ministres du doigt c'est vrai qu'on nous
avait dit y a pas besoin de masquer un
au départ justement à l'époque où son
papa est décédé il n'y a pas besoin de
masque en fait on en avait pas
clairement elle parle de mensonge
y a pas un peu de ça quand même rémy
rebeyrotte n'y avait pas de masque et on
nous disait pas on mettra tout
simplement parce que je n'avais pas vous
savez des décisions du pommier des
premiers conseils de scientifiques
extrêmement différent qui s'exprimait
certains disaient faut absolument des
masques d'autres disaient on peut les
masques ne sont pas utiles
le notamment sur la voie publique enfin
je me rappelle comme tout le monde de
cette période où il ya une extrême
confusion aussi bien d'ailleurs des
sciences que des politiques qui était
conseillé par des scientifiques mais
même disait on ne sait pas grand chose
je le rappelle
là encore nous étions tout au début 2000
l'hôpital lui-même était en grande
difficulté que je ne dira sans doute des
raisons évidemment enfin il faut
reconnaître si vous voulez nous étions
tous dans une situation extrêmement
content et jusqu'au jusqu'au ont
finement sévère difficile
il a fallu que nous subissions tous pour
essayer de maîtriser
allez on perd vous vous écoutez ce
témoignage également quel est votre
sentiment vous partager la vie de rémy
rebeyrotte finalement voilà c'était le
début on a tâtonné on a pris les
mauvaises décisions mais ya pas vraiment
en substance un jour je laissais de
traduire les propos il ya pas vraiment
de deux fautes caractérisées de l'état
c'est votre avis aussi
maintenant je je je comprends la colère
et le besoin de justice de clara 1
bouaziz parce que lui l'exécutif depuis
le début de cette épidémie nous est
totalement infantilisée l'enfermer n'a
laissé ni aux citoyens ni ni aux
médecins de ville et aux parlementaires
la moindre liberté face à ce virus
il y avait un protocole protocole
sanitaire au total politique à suivre
sans possibilité de s'écarter
il ya un revers à cette infantilisation
c'est la responsabilité des défaillances
et des défaillances y en a eu beaucoup
énormément il ya eu les masques toutes
ces polémiques
les tests avec le calibrage des tests et
maintenant des vaccins donc on est
vraiment dans un système pervers ou
toute la communication du gouvernement
depuis depuis un an est fondée sur la
peur et la méfiance
et pour nous forcer la pourquoi la peur
pour nous forcer d'adhérer sans
réfléchir à des mesures qui sont
décidées sans concertation y compris
imposées parlementaires dont c'est la
mission de réfléchir avec le
gouvernement il faut qu'il y ait un lien
entre le gouvernement et le législatif
et le parlement ça c'est très important
et je pense que le l'exécutif a raté le
coche en ne mettant pas son parlement
dans la vie c'est parce que il est
important de dans un état de faire état
nation ou une formation c'est faire
participer les gens c'est faire
participer des parlementaires ça n'a pas
été fait alors il ya un autre point on
va y revenir justement rien autre point
qui a été souvent pointé du doigt c'est
la lourdeur administrative de notre pays
une problématique soulevée d'ailleurs
par pas mal de politiques un regard des
à titre d'exemple le tweet du maire de
cannes david lisnard c'était fin
novembre est la crise due qu'au guide
révèle la folie bureaucratique française
rémy rebeyrotte c'est une critique que
vous partagez vous savez cette prise
elle révèle surtout une chose c'est que
ce pays semble impossible réunit l'union
nationale je ne sais pas si ça existe
encore ça existait fut un temps dans ce
pays cette capacité si vous voulez à se
mettre tous ensemble a hérité
d'exploiter au plan politique une
situation de crise grave
j'observe que ça n'est plus possible
c'est à dire que certains ont fait leur
ligne politique d'une crise qui aurait
des tous nous rassembler pour essayer de
trouver des solutions et les devants
j'observe d'ailleurs je mets de côté les
élus locaux
parce que la plupart des élus locaux
pour eux ce sont tous ces les manches
avec les préfets pour trouver des
solutions et des solutions les plus
efficaces possibles sur le terrain pour
faire avancer à chaque étape les
solutions pour la population alors je
peux vous dire étant à l'assemblée
nationale maintient à 7
n'attendez pas aujourd'hui hélas d'un
certain de politique au niveau national
cette capacité à dire écoutez on met de
côté les divisions on se met tous
ensemble on essaye de trouver des
solutions
moi je les villes us y a à plusieurs
reprises et je le regrette parce que je
pense que quand on est dans un état
d'urgence sanitaire on doit trouver
ensemble normalement dès les solutions
pour avancer
donnez moi on arrive presque à la fin de
notre face à face déjà
justement vous dites et politiques
nationaux c'est bien là où le bât blesse
souvent on a entendu genre père le
président la région de rente est
concédée décrit et c'était pas le seul
on n'a pas assez donné la main aux
régions au terrain ça a été l'un des
grands problèmes de cette crise et ça
continue d'ailleurs
évidemment on le voit tous les jours
avec la campagne de vaccination à la
houppe r ça ne sert pas de leçon on
n'arrive pas à se dépêtrer de cet état
centralisé jacobins monsieur rebeyrotte
a dit que le vivre ensemble ou décider
ensemble n'existe plus mais je suis
optimiste il existe il suffit d'écouter
le parlement et ne pas être pas écouter
seulement l'assemblée nationale qui est
aux ordres du gouvernement écouter aussi
au sénat nous nous validons l'état
d'urgence c'est une situation
exceptionnelle mais nous faisons tout
pour qu'elles ne deviennent pas la règle
et puis on a parlé de technocratie tout
à l'heure c'est une technocratie
triomphante parce que c'est elle qui
commande c'est elle qui prive les élus
locaux de leur liberté et on a vu les
départements les régions dans la
délivrance des mas cité de catastrophe
les maires les maires dans le cadre du
confinement il ya des villages qui n'ont
jamais vu un seul cadre qu vide et on
applique les mêmes rails notant certains
villages où il n'ya pas de souci où il
ya des distanciation les mêmes règles
que dans les métropoles
donc l'état a privé les élus locaux de
la moindre liberté et on a vu cette
technocratie triomphante on a vu pendant
la période de noël où il a fallu pas
moins du premier ministre et de trois
ministres à côté de lui pour signer la
possibilité de vendre des
les sapins de noël à l'extérieur donc
c'est quand même c'est quand même un
ridicule et on a vu aussi ce ridicule
dans les fameux rayon non l'essentiel on
voyait des rayons dans les supermarchés
qui sont complètement gâchée ne laissons
pas le pouvoir à cette technocratie qui
n'a pas la capacité humaine qu'on les
élus locaux faisons confiance aux
parlementaires les faisant confiance aux
locaux comme l'a dit monsieur rebeyrotte
c'est très important et il vient de
saône et loire il sait ce que c'est
qu'un élu local
c'est un des deux qui mouillent mouiller
la chemise qui relève ses manches et qui
est proche du du quotidien qui projet
d'habitants et souvenez vous de la
campagne de monsieur mâcon qui disait
qu'il voulait une campagne horizontal il
voulait une décision horizontale y en a
vu depuis et cette crise qu vite que de
cette décision verticale et quand le
peuple gronde qu'est-ce qui fait
monsieur mac il crée un comité citoyen
théodule où on désigne au au sort
quelques quelques candidats et puis
quand un député ou un mini d'un sénateur
gronde les bat on envoie un ministre
pour dans l'hémicycle pour lui dire que
c'est pas la bonne question la semaine
dernière je me posais une question au
premier ministre sur les universités
il a été indigné que je puisse supposer
la question il a jugé irresponsable de
rouvrir l'université pas la question du
cosef n'était pas la question se posait
je suis aussi indigné quand je vois
olivier ferrand répondre à madame
martine bonnaire cette semaine la
semaine
merci pardonnez moi je suis désolé j'ai
oublié de vous couper à la on perd mais
on est vraiment arrivé tout au bout de
notre débat merci en tout cas compris le
respect oui pardon je souhaite que le
l'exécutif respecte les parlementaires
et les élus et maires de ce territoire
qui s'appelle la france et ça sera le
nom de la femme mère si elle a ou perdus
merci également parmi revers d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france restez
avec nous dans quelques instants
quelques petites secondes on partira aux
états unis où procès en destitution de
donald trump se poursuit au lendemain
la diffusion des machettes de l'eso du
capitole le président joe biden annonce
la création d'un groupe de travail pour
définir une stratégie ferme face à la
chine également et nous irons également
en iran où on produit désormais de
l'uranium métal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à 20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct
sur rt france si vous nous rejoignez aux
etats-unis le procès en destitution de
donald trump se poursuit au sénat est la
séance doit reprendre aujourd'hui à midi
l'ex président est jugé pour incitation
à l'insurrection dans le capitole par
amitié par ses partisans le 6 janvier
dernier les élus démocrates ont témoigné
des violences vidéo choc et citations
choisies à l'appui et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct depuis washington
avec tristan cabello maître de
conférences en civilisation américaine à
l'université johns hopkins et notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir tristan cabello merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france le
président joe biden qui estime
aujourd'hui en que ce fossé peut être
fait et évoluer à les opinions sur son
prédécesseur au lendemain d'un exposé de
l'assaut sur le capital par les
démocrates
à votre avis ça pourrait être le cas
dans un tram sort est en train de voir
son image change eh oui c'est tout à
fait le cas c'est à dire qu on a même
l'impression que jo bats est que en fait
donald trump est déjà passé à autre
chose
par contre il semblerait que
ce procès dinkic mount ne plaisent pas
trop aux américains en fait il ne semble
pas très intéressé par ce procès il faut
dire que on en a déjà eu un donald trump
est parti de la maison blanche
et ce procès là prend la place
médiatique
j'ai envie de dire des lois qui
devraient en fait être prises par
l'administration baril donnent on est en
pleine crise sanitaire économique social
et en fait ce procès ne répond pas
vraiment aux attentes des américains eux
en ce moment c'est à dire qu'est ce
qu'ils attendent ces américains en ce
moment alors ce qu'on a vu le 6 janvier
pour moi ça n'était pas le retour de
l'extrême droite du racisme du fascisme
aux états unis j'ai vu beaucoup de mes
collègues étaient filés sur les plateaux
télévision nous nous dire que c'était le
cas moi je crois que ce qu'on a vu
le 6 janvier c'était une grande détresse
économique en fait c'est à dire ce sont
des gens des américains qui n'arrivent
plus à payer leur loyer qui n'arrivent
plus à subvenir à leurs besoins qui
n'arrivent plus à payer des études à
leurs enfants et qui ont besoin de
réponses concrètes et alors ce que l'on
voit là c'est que le parti démocrate se
défilent déjà après seulement deux
semaines de pouvoir vous souvenez lors
de l'élection géorgie joe biden était
d'aller en géorgie avait dit si vous
vous laissez pas me cheikh de stimulus
de digne de 2000 $
et bien il faut absolument voter pour
ces deux candidats démocrates et bien là
qu'est ce que l'on voit juste deux
semaines après que ces chèques de
stimulus sont déjà descendus à 14 cents
à 1400 $ pour les américains dont
examens qui ont besoin vraiment de deux
mesures fortes
il ya une grande détresse économique
dans le pays et je crois que ce procès
vraiment c'est du folklore de washington
qui va de plus en plus agrandir le fossé
entre les élites et le peuple américain
justement signé on vous croit enfin en
croire en tout cas en creux ce que vous
nous dites est ce que ça pourrait pas
faire faire de
notre hub une victime est rehaussée
plutôt son image justement loin des
élites
oui alors c'est tout à fait le discours
que donald trump a joué depuis
depuis 2000 16 me reste que j'ai envie
de dire je crois que le parti démocrate
en fait les élites du parti démocrate
ont vraiment besoin d'un parti
républicain fort pour exister et un
parti républicain force est un parti
républicain fort dans l'establishment et
ça veut dire je crois un parti qui est
sans donald re c'est le temps que donald
trump et dans le parti républicain
il est encore un ennemi un problème pour
le parti démocrate est pour le parti
républicain d'ailleurs s'il est hors de
ce parti il pour avoir un discours
médiatique un discours politique mais
hors de ce parti il a peu d'avenir
institutionnel et politique en fait
alors lors de ce deuxième jour de procès
les procureurs démocrates ont voulu
démontrer que donald trump avait chauffé
à blanc ses partisans pendant de longues
semaines avant les incidents du capitole
une estime que ce sont des preuves est
ce que on peut considérer que c'est
assez explicites ou on attend justement
les avocats n'ont alors il n'ya pour
l'instant finalement aucune preuve et
c'est très difficile en fait de prouver
les charges contre donald trump puisque
il est accusé d'incitation à la
situation à la protestation
donc le grand problème c'est de comment
connecter en fait ses discours ses
tweets en l'occurrence et les actions
des protestants les protest des
prothèses des gens qui protestaient et
donc ça c'est très difficile pour pour
le parti démocrate de prouver cette
connexion fx qu'on a vu aussi fière et
je crois qu'on va le voir beaucoup plus
aujourd'hui la défense de donald trump
est très très faible c'est à dire que je
regardais je regrette tout ça en anglais
hier ça faisait vraiment très très peu
de sens je me demandais même qu on
pouvait traduire un tel discours
donc la défense est très faible et en
même temps il faut quand même rappeler
que il faut 17 voix républicaine au
sénat pour que de notre homme soit
empêchée et que c'est c'est tres ça
n'arrivera pas on se demande quel est
l'intérêt au final de ce procès puisque
cette destitution un peu de chance de
passer il ya un intérêt on imagine
l'image à casser l'image de donald trump
de la part des démocrates mais est ce
qui nous vaut ya parvenir c'est pas
forcément sûr au final quel est
l'intérêt oui je crois que c'est la
question qui est sur toutes les lèvres
je crois qu'on se demande tous un peu
quel est l'intérêt de ce procès puisque
donna train des parties je crois qu'il
n'a pas vraiment de projet de revenir en
politique je crois qu'il veut
capitaliser sur sa sur sa personnalité
médiatique et les démocrates ont tout à
perdre en fait dans ce dans ce procès
puisque les américains n'attendent pas
vraiment un énième procès en destitution
contre donald trump il attend des
mesures fortes économique social
sanitaire
donc il est très difficile pour moi de
vous dire exactement quelle est la
raison même de communication derrière
derrière derrière ce procès dans un
empêchement
en tout cas ce que je sais c'est que
donald trump est beaucoup plus dangereux
pour les démocrates et pour les
républicains
à l'intérieur du parti républicain et il
faut absolument qu'il n'en sorte pour
tristan camillo vous restez avec nous
parce qu'on va évoquer cette fois-ci joe
biden et ses relations avec la chine
parce que pendant ce temps le successeur
de donald trump s'est entretenu avec le
président chinois xi jingping joe biden
à lui a fait part jeudi de ses profondes
inquiétudes au sujet de la répression
hong kong et des atteintes aux droits de
l'homme au zhejiang la relation à
washington pékin toujours tendu donc en
témoigne cette visite au pentagone hier
du président américain
on voit les détails avant de retrouver
notre invité de walid bennani un salut
militaire dans la peau d'un nouveau rôle
celui de commandant en chef des armées
joe biden s'est rendu dans un édifice
empreint d'histoire
le président américain attentif lors de
sa visite guidée d'une exposition rendre
hommage au personnel afro-américain des
armées enjoy dance scruter et déterminés
à répondre aux défis des adversaires des
états unis
aujourd'hui j'ai été informé d'un
nouveau groupe de travail du département
de la défense sur la chine que deux
secrétaires austin a mis en place pour
examiner notre stratégie et nos concepts
opérationnels
notre technologie notre dispositif de
forces et bien d'autres choses encore
le 46e président américain rappelle un
effort de l'ensemble du gouvernement
face aux questions liées à l' empire du
milieu avec deux maîtres mots alliances
et partenariats solides un futur groupe
de travail composé de quinze conseillers
civils et militaires c'est ainsi que
nous relèverons le défi de la chine et
veilleront à ce que le peuple américain
gagne la compétition de l'avenir la
maison blanche a informé dans la foulée
de cette visite au pentagone d'un coup
de fil entre le président chinois xi
jinping et son homologue américain le
premier depuis l'arrivée de joe biden à
la maison blanche
pratique économique contraignantes hong
kong taïwan ou encore le dossier des
ouigours beaucoup de divergences dans
une compétition stratégique
de son côté pékin via son média d'état
joue l'apaisement
les questions relatives à ce sujet
concerne la souveraineté et l'intégrité
territoriale de la chine la partie
américaine devrait traiter ces questions
avec prudence le gouvernement chinois
espère une meilleure relation bilatérale
citant un moment crucial dans leurs
relations
les ministères des affaires étrangères
des deux pays peuvent avoir un échange
de vues approfondis sur les relations
bilatérales et les grandes questions
internationales et régionales
les ministères de l'économie des
finances de la police et de l'armée
peuvent avoir davantage de contacts la
chine et les états unis devraient
rétablir différents types de mécanismes
de dialogue pour mieux comprendre les
intentions politiques de l'autre éviter
les malentendus et les erreurs de
jugement la pandémie de kovy de 19 et le
changement climatique au centre
également des discussions entre les deux
dirigeants
l' usage de la force doit être le
dernier recours a fait remarquer joe
biden au sujet de sa future politique
étrangère
on vous retrouve au tristan cabello
maître de conférences en civilisation
américaine à l'université johns hopkins
on a vu ce premier appel un musclé entre
joe biden et xing gym bing pour le
dialogue finalement à tous même parvenu
à se faire doit-on s'attendre à la même
ligne agressive que sous donald trump
je crois qu'en effet il n'y aura pas
beaucoup de changements sur cette ligne
avec les relations avec la chine
vous savez les politique étrangère
américaine a sont toujours basés sur la
désignation d'un ennemi
ça ça n'a pas changé mais l'ennemi
change peu à peu près tous tous les cinq
ans et donc là il semblerait que ça soit
la chine comme comme sous le mandat de
donner train et devrait continuer dans
ce sens alors il a fermé t'es de biden
qui doit bien sûr se montrer assez fort
sur le plan international mais encore
une fois là je crains que ça ça ne
répondent pas finalement aux enjeux que
les américains se posent les américains
en ce moment ne se préoccupe pas de ce
qui se passe avec la chine des relations
entre la chine et les états unis joe
biden doit se présidentialiser durant
les premières semaines de son mandat et
il est évident que c'est un forum pour
lui ici alors joe biden qui veut mettre
l'accent en tout cas sur le respect des
droits humains même si les américains
s'en fiche sur lui il en a parlé qu'il
estime bafoués en chine
la question quelle légitimité aux yeux
de pékin pourrait avoir les états unis
cette initiative
pékin qui pourrait j'imagine dénoncé une
ingérence
oui alors pratiquement aucune en fait
mais joe biden ici essaye bien sûr de
faire plaisir à la gauche du parti
démocrate et il le fait très bien et
c'est à dire que avec plusieurs
initiatives un les droits de l'homme
human rights sur deux problématiques du
climat au saut à bien aussi il faut
savoir que joe biden
à nommer des gens voilà qui ont beaucoup
plus à la frange la plus progressiste du
parti démocrate est donc ici il fait un
travail assez bons sur des sujets qui
sont souvent perdus d'avancé on a envie
de dire parce que l'on avec le climat
mais en tout cas il
il ménage l'ale plus progressistes de
son parti démocrate avec la politique
extérieure en fait en tout cas de jeu
bayonne semble vouloir prendre des
sanctions à droite à gauche hier contre
les généraux birmans et sans vouloir
s'ingérer dans les affaires
internationales durant son mandat est ce
qu'on va assister au retour des états
unis comme gendarme du monde avec celui
qui distribue les bons et les mauvais
points
oui moi je crois que le grand problème
de jordan c'est qu'il n'a pas fait le
test de son software politique et
spécialement pour les pour les
politiques internationales
je crois que c'est quelqu'un qui est
toujours un peu scotché sous le second
mandat de barack obama
moi je crois qu'il peut y avoir vraiment
une une rhinite et initiations des
politique extérieure américaine
ce sont les premières semaines il se
tâte ils ne savent pas trop ce qu'il ce
qu'ils vont faire mais en tout cas les
états unis ne peuvent plus être le
gendarme du monde et ce n'est pas ce que
les américains attendent
merci beaucoup tristan qu'amélie au
maître de conférences en civilisation
américaine amène vers cité johns hopkins
de nous avoir accompagnés merci à vous
la russie menace l'union européenne de
représailles en cas de nouvelles
sanctions à les recommandations du chef
de la diplomatie européenne joseph
bourrel de sanctionner monstres ou après
l'expulsion du pays de trois diplomates
européens ne sont pas du tout goût de
moscou la porte parole de la diplomatie
russe a haussé le ton écoute et je
voudrais mettre en garde nos partenaires
européens sur toute nouvelle démarche
inconsidérés elle sera suivie aînés
xsara bleue mans comme vous le comprenez
d'une réponse proportionnée il est
absolument inacceptable d'utiliser les
droits humains et des principes
démocratiques comme des instruments
géopolitique est une première depuis dix
ans la russie participent à des
exercices avec les pays de l'otan cette
manoeuvre
à vannes internationale se nomme ammann
2021 est organisée par le pakistan et
débute aujourd'hui
parmi les 45 pays participants la
réussit donc on le disait mais aussi des
états unis la turquie et même la chine
l'otan ne participe pas en tant que tel
aux exercices la correspondante à moscou
d'antoine claireaux quand on évoque le
sujet des exercices militaires c'est la
plupart du temps synonyme de hausse des
tensions de menaces aux frontières la
russie pense par exemple à ceux
organisés en europe de l'est par l'otan
tandis qu'alain verse l'alliance
atlantique voir d'un mauvais oeil ce
organisé en russie occidentale
mais cette fois tous ces protagonistes
se retrouvent du même côté dans des
manoeuvres organisées par la marine
pakistanaise en mer d'arabie
l'objectif favoriser la coopération
internationale pour lutter contre la
piraterie et le terrorisme
merci beaucoup
dans le cadre des exercices nous allons
coopérer faire des manoeuvres conjointes
et nous ferons preuve ensemble d'un
niveau élevé de compétences en matière
navale
le ministère russe de la défense a fait
savoir que la russie était représentée
par trois navires issue de sa flotte de
la mer noire
ainsi qu'une unité d'infanterie de
marine et une équipe de démineurs même
si des bâtiments russes et américains
risquent donc de se côtoyer
il ne s'agit pas de manoeuvres
conjointes comme l'a précisé un porte
parole de l'otan chaque pays participent
à ces exercices sur invitation du
pakistan certes mais de manière autonome
cela n'en reste pas moins une prouesse
diplomatique pour islamabad
la dernière fois que les forces navales
russes et celle de l'alliance atlantique
avaient participé à deux même manoeuvre
c'était en 2011 il y a dix ans au large
de l'espagne
moscou appelle l'iran à la retenue après
la production d'uranium métal après le
retrait des états unis de l'accord sur
le nucléaire iranien organisé par donald
trump en 2010 8 terrans s'émancipe une
nouvelle violation de ses engagements
envers timo ce coup là vice-ministre
russe des affaires étrangères appelle
les etats-unis à lever les sanctions
contre l'iran pour résoudre cette
situation le plus vite possible et pour
en parler nous sommes avec un coup
roches chamlou avocat au barreau de
paris spécialiste des relations
internationales
mon soir quand je vous remercie d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france l'iran
qui a donc démarré à la production
d'uranium métal pour alimenter son
réacteur de recherche à ce que cette
nouvelle a de quoi inquiéter ses
nouvelles de huy a de quoi inquiéter
parce que comme vous savez dernièrement
joe biden a fait une interview télé et
il a dit et il avait bien précisé
aujourd'hui aux journalistes que il
souhaitait rejoindre la porte sur le
nucléaire mais qu'il n'allait pas levé
les sanctions en premier dans ce cas si
les iraniens essaient de mettre de la
pression en disant que si vous continuez
si vous continuez à une autre politique
de pression maximale et que si vous ne
levait pas les sanctions comme et nous
on va enrichir l'uranium
de plus en plus jusqu'à un pont ou pas
acquérir la
la levée des sanctions justement ça
serait une bonne stratégie de façon à
pondérer et à reprendre les négociations
avec l'iran c'est ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'il faut faire
absolument
est ce qu'il n'ya pas d'autre choix si
les américains de lézignan par acquérir
la monuc teurs gdaxi d'été et les
capacités pour acquérir et si dans le
cas par des syndicats continue
les maxima ils n'ont juste un sweat
shops est clairement différent puisqu'il
arrive pas et par des jets de pierre
laigle bien voilà on espère qu'on va
vous récupérez cochevelou parce que la
liaison et n'est pas très bonnes gens
tentent quand même une une question
l'iran qui demande donc aux états unis
de lever les sanctions pour que le pays
retourne à ses engagements maiden de son
côté 1 qui a annoncé souhaiter une
reprise du dialogue mais ne fera pas le
premier pas pour lever les sanctions
c'est un peu un dialogue de sourds est
ce que le fait justement de violer une
partie de la corde 2015 avec cet uranium
métal c'était la bonne façon pour lui
rendre renouer le dialogue
tout de même non je ne pense pas que ce
soit la bonne façon puisque l'iran en
fait tu veux mettre la pression sur les
américains pour qu'ils rejoindre
l'apport en premier puisque du point de
vue iranien ce sont les américains qui
ont quitté de l'apport en premier et
c'est les américains qui ont imposé de
nouvelles sanctions sur l'iran
c'est pour ça que l'iran dit qu'il faut
que les américains lèvent les sanctions
faut que les iraniens continuent à
rester engagement et ce qu'il faut
savoir on prêt à négocier sur migrants
et que même le même si dit que le
ricaneux les faits les sanctions qui le
veut au fond de lui il ya de plus en
plus de chômeurs âgés en iran les prix
grimpent tous les jours et confie un
autre bijou faut que les pays revienne à
la table
mais pas ses tacles messieurs arrive à
opérations ou scoop ça soit fait de
manière sécurisée et donner sa vie du
liban enrichi plus maintenant enfin à
mesure et safari les 100 pure invention
aussi de façon synchrone aucun des deux
ne parle
merci quand au châble ou avocat au
barreau de paris et veuillez nous
excuser pour cette liaison voilà assez
médiocre malheureusement un pommeau de
réseaux internet merci à vous dans le
reste de l'actualité on les
manifestations contre la réforme
agricole se poursuivent et les leaders
fortement présents sur twitter voient
leur compte suspendu une demande du
premier ministre à rendre à maudit les
précisions de cyrielle benavides bulbul
ans après une première tentative début
février le gouvernement indien
renouvelle ses voeux au réseau social
twitter bloqué quelques 250 compte ou
tweets d'utilisateurs indien qui
représenterait une grave menace pour
l'ordre public
parmi eux des militants des
représentants syndicaux du monde de
l'agriculture ou encore des leaders de
l'opposition
et si twitter s'est montré réticent en
suspendant quelques comptes le 1er
février puis en les débloquant quelques
heures plus tard cette fois
narendra modi le premier ministre n'a
pas hésité à menacer la plateforme
américaine de poursuites pénales allant
jusqu'à l'éventuel emprisonnement
d'employés locaux
ce mercredi twitter a indiqué avoir
suspendu de façon permanente plusieurs
comptes et d'autres seulement en inde
pourtant l'incertitude demeure nous ne
croyons pas que les actions qui ont été
ordonnées et est conforme à la loi
indienne
conformément à nos principes de défense
de liberté d'expression nous n'avons
pris aucune mesure à l'encontre de
comptes constitué d'entités médiatique
deux journalistes de militants et de
politiciens nous pensons qu'agir comme
exigé violerait leur droit fondamental
de liberté d'expression
en vertu de la loi indienne et si
twitter s'est immiscé dans le bras de
fer qui oppose gouvernement est
agriculteur depuis le mois de novembre
c'est parce que les manifestants contre
les réformes agricoles unifient leurs
forces sur le réseau social
jusqu'à interpellé deux icônes mondiales
la chanteuse rihanna et la militante
greta sonberg
un espoir pour cet habitant puisqu'il
s'agissait de l'une des plus grandes
manifestations pacifiques jamais
organisé depuis des décennies il fallait
absolument qu'elle attire l'attention
d'un public international comme vous
pouvez le constater lorsque le
gouvernement indien a tenté de couper
internet l'électricité et
l'approvisionnement en eau le public
international s'est réveillé et a décidé
qu'il devait maintenant parler de la
détresse permanente à laquelle les
agriculteurs sont confrontés les ong
internationale reporters sans frontières
a qualifié ces suspensions de compte
deux cas choquants de censure manifeste
et si l'inde est souvent présentée comme
la plus grande démocratie au monde selon
vos porter sans frontières le pays se
place seulement au 142e rang sur 180 du
classement de la liberté de la presse en
2020 mais en thaïlande plusieurs
centaines de manifestants se sont
rassemblés hier à bangkok pour exiger la
libération de quatre militants tous
placés en détention provisoire dans
l'attenté de leur procès pour insulte au
roi de thaïlande et sont à la tête du
mouvement qui réclame depuis un an la
démission du gouvernement et une réforme
de la monarchie nicolas petit qu'ils
soient munis de pancartes ou qu'il
frappe sur des casseroles c'est
thaïlandais n'ont pas envie de se taire
mercredi il était un peu plus d'un
millier dans la capitale à se faire
entendre
depuis hier
quatre personnes ont été arrêtées par le
tribunal au sujet de l'article 112
c'est à dire la loi thaïlandaise sur le
lèse majesté
hier on a mis a été arrêté ils ont
besoin de nous nous devons nous exprimer
pour les libérer et dénoncer cette
injustice dans notre pays à la tête du
mouvement de jeunesse contestataire
entamé en juillet pour demander
notamment la démission du gouvernement
et une réforme de la monarchie
quatre leaders ont été inculpés mardi
pour sédition un crime passible de sept
ans de prison
abrogée en 2018 la loi de lèse majesté a
été rétablie par le roi rama 10 en
novembre et mesure inédite
la demande de liberté provisoire a été
refusé aux quatre leaders de la
manifestation
la goutte de trop je ne peux pas
accepter ce gouvernement et le fait
qu'il utilise l'article 112 pour se
débarrasser des personnes qui
s'expriment et de la liberté
d'expression
c'est injuste la loi n'est pas valable
je peux faire tout ce que je peux pour
me joindre à cette manifestation et
faire de mon mieux je ne sais pas
comment nous pouvons nous exprimer
autrement
selon les ong tigers for human rights 58
militants font face à diverses
accusations de lèse majesté et encourent
jusqu'à 15 ans de prison
en alignant les peines une situation qui
inquiète jusqu'aux nations unies nous
sommes profondément troublés par la
hausse signalé du nombre de poursuites
pour lèse majesté depuis fin 2020 et les
peines de prison infligées qui semble
plus sévère en décembre le bureau des
droits de l'homme des nations unies
avait appelé la thaïlande amender la loi
soit quoi le monarque thaïlandais ne
semblent pas disposées en janvier la
thaïlandaise anchan pris l'air avait été
condamné à une peine de 43 ans de prison
pour avoir posté des vidéos où elle
critiquait le roi
ces publications remonter à 2015 reste
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons la mise en examen de deux
policiers dans le cadre de l' enquête
ouverte lié à la blessure à l'oeil de
gilet jaune régis roma rodriguez fin
janvier 2019 à paris et puis dans
viendront sur la situation sanitaire
olivier ferrand s'est exprimé tout à
l'heure il estime que chaque semaine que
nous gagnons sur ce variant est une
semaine de respiration pour notre pays
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous de
cecco politique n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent en soi vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche prg extrêmement
intéressant
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham changer
l'équilibré stratégique pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complexe robe était le
seul à pouvoir créer une mission d'une
paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qu'une ira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accros de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata papa papa pata pata
vous avez envie de faire ça mais il faut
que leur qu'istres groove la musique
c'est la traduction la plus poétique de
la vie si vous mettez pas la vie des
vides à mon sens bête
il faut sortir les notes de leurs
univers carcéral v il faut jouer ce qui
a entre les notes et avant tout c'est le
rythme et la pulsation et ça c'est
fondamental pour entraîner et l'
enthousiasme des musiciens et celui du
public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
or
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre pour cette deuxième
heure d'émission tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi 11
février les premières poursuit dans ce
dossier deux policiers mis en examen
dans le cadre de l' enquête ouverte il
ya la blessure à l'oeil du gilet jaune
jérôme rodriguez cette figure connue du
mouvement avait été épargné lors de la
11e journée de mobilisation à paris fin
janvier 2019 par un éclat de grenade
les deux policiers sont placés sous
contrôle judiciaire jérôme rodriguez
sera notre invité dans quelques instants
chaque semaine gagner est une semaine de
respiration insiste olivier verrons lors
du point hebdomadaire sur la situation
sanitaire
les variants progresse le britannique
représenterait 25% des cas les
brésiliens et sud-africains 4 à 5%
le ministre de la santé qui assure que
tout sera fait pour éviter un nouveau
confinement pas de vaccin contre le coc
witmer
des dividendes en hausse 'l'annonce
sanofi de verser plus de 4 milliards
d'euros à ses actionnaires alors qu'ils
suppriment des emplois notamment dans la
recherche suscite la polémique mais
cette augmentation dividendes en pleine
crise sanitaire est elle aussi
scandaleuse qu'elle n'y paraît c'est la
question à laquelle tentera de répondre
jacques sapir autant son édito rico ce
soit en italie le mouvement 5 étoiles
s'est prononcé en faveur du gouvernement
d'unité nationale dirigé par mario
draghi un dernier obstacle franchi qui
ouvre la voie à la naissance d'un
gouvernement de l'ex président de la
banque centrale européenne il pourrait
être annoncé dès vendredi
[Musique]
les premières poursuites dans ce dossier
médiatique deux policiers mis en examen
dans le cadre de l'enquêté ouverte lié à
la blessure à l'oeil du gilet jaune
jérôme rodriguez
cette figure connue du mouvement avaient
été bornier lors de la 11e journée de
mobilisation c'était le 26 janvier 2019
à paris par un éclat de grenade le
policier accusé d'avoir lancé la grenade
qui a causé la perte de l'oeil droit été
mis en examen du chef de violences
volontaires ayant entraîné une
mutilation ou une infirmité permanente
aggravé qualification passible des
assises
l'autre policier lui est poursuivi pour
des violences volontaires aggravées sur
un autre manifestant
les deux agences sont placés sous
contrôle judiciaire
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
jérôme rodriguez c'est notre rubrique
l'invité ce soir bonsoir jérôme
rodrigues merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france une première étape
serait importante donc dans ce dossier
quelle est la réaction à ces décisions
alors la réaction elle est un petit peu
confuse parce que j'ai quelque part du
mal à concrétiser ce que peut
représenter une mise en examen donc donc
c'est j'ai du mal un petit peu analysé
les choses après avec du recul en
entendant parler en entendant parler mon
avocat et diverses personnes c'est
quelque chose qui est quand même assez
énorme apparemment équipe qui peut
porter ses fruits maintenant on va
éviter tout triomphalisme
et on essaiera d'être heureux le jour où
la sentence sera rendue et que la
justice ne sera rendue
en tout cas il ya une forme même si
évidemment il n'y a pas eu de jugement
bien évidemment il ya une forme de mise
en responsabilité potentielle de ces
policiers c'est quelque chose en tout
cas qui compte pour la victime que vous
n'êtes pas très clairement parce que ça
fait deux ans qu'on est quand même dans
l'attenté d'une décision quelconque au
vu des preuves et de l'ensemble des
vidéos qui ont été tournés ce jour là
sur le sur l'acte du l'acte du 26
janvier 2019 jour où j'ai été bornier
c'est regrettable que ça prenne autant
de temps il ya d'autres affaires en
justice à laquelle je suis convié où ça
prend beaucoup moins de temps donc bon
voilà c'est un bon début forcément
j'espère que on ira au delà de ça et
qu'on pourra aller au jugement pour
pouvoir déterminer l'ensemble des
responsabilités de la chaîne de
responsabilités face à ce qui m'est
arrivé je suis resté patient pendant
deux ans en essayant de parler un
minimum justement de de la faire pour
que celle ci puisse aller au bout sans
avoir de soucis
maintenant que cette annonce et est
apparue et qu'on va laisser faire un
petit peu le phénomène médiatique je
vais retourner dans le calme et et
laisser faire à la fois les juges les
enquêteurs et l'avocat leur travail pour
pouvoir justement pouvoir récupérer
justice presque deux ans après cette
décision enfin depuis les actes comment
justement vous expliquez vous cette
longueur écoutez la première surprise
c'est que j'étais parti du principe que
temps que notre président macron serait
tôt au pouvoir il serait difficile que
j'obtienne justice donc bon déjà la
justice m'a fait mentir quelque part et
j'en suis agréablement surpris
maintenant
maintenant faut vraiment que ça aille au
bout et que et que
et que le travail puisse bien se faire
vous savez le problème en soi c'est pas
la justice on parle beaucoup de la
justice moi j'ai un parti pris qui est
le suivant pour que la justice puisse
bien faire son travail il faut en même
temps qu'elle puisse avoir les bonnes
pièces les bonnes preuves toutes les
pièces justificatives qui permettront à
la justice pour justement pouvoir être
rendu aujourd'hui les enquêtes
appartenant à l'igpn donc des policiers
qui enquêtent sur des policiers est ce
que toute la lumière est faite justement
de parler rapport de l'igpn pour que
pour que la justice puisse se faire
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je milite
aussi pour que il puisse y avoir des
enquêtes indépendantes pour en tout cas
sur les exactions de policiers vis-à-vis
des citoyens pour que la justice puisse
avoir les bonnes pièces et être rendu
pour l'ensemble des victimes et de leurs
familles selon vous jérôme rodriguez
cette affaire votre affaire est ce
qu'elle est devenue politique en quelque
sorte à voir quoi qu'il arrive je suis
devenu un opposant politique du mois à
la politique de macron donc au vu de ce
qui se passe dans de nombreux pays
il est clair qu'on cherche à me faire
taire il n'y a pas eu que l'impact
l'impact de la balle ou de la grenade
qui m'a éborgné le 26 il ya tout ce qui
y ans qui s'en est suivi en terme de
pression sur ma vie sur sur les
désagréments qu'ils ont pu suivre ou ou
sur les mises en accusation que j'ai pu
avoir de la part du gouvernement ou de
la part de certains ministres ou députés
vous avez se faire traiter de débile
mental en direct à la télé il faut quand
même de la part de responsables au
gouvernement faut quand même encaissé ça
pendant pendant deux ans 100 ans sans
même pouvoir avoir un droit de réponse
par me parmi ces gens là bien entendu
donc
ils m'ont fait je vais vous dire ces
gens là le gouvernement l'état
l'impression qu'ils ont mis à la fois
sur sur ma personne et sur ma famille
m'ont fait beaucoup plus de mal que les
deux policiers qui m'ont crevé l'oeil
quand vous parlez de pression jérôme
perdre ide eux ne paieront jamais de
leurs responsabilités quand vous parlez
de pression vous pensez à quoi
vous savez des contrôles d'impôt sur ma
famille des contrôles d'urssaf je me
prends j'en suis pratiquement à 2000
2500 euros damende des amendes que je ne
reçois pas à mon domicile à laquelle on
ne les signifie pas dans la rue parce
que je vous rappelle que je suis persona
non grata pour messieurs l'allemand le
samedi à paris et au final elles
finissent pas comment dire atterrir sur
la somme de 400 euros ils viennent ceux
directement se servir sur mes comptes
des rappels d'impôts avec des sommes à
payer enfin voilà et de beaucoup de
choses vous je vous cache pas les
insultes que je peux prendre de la part
du gouvernement où l'effectif news que
j'ai pu recevoir de la part de madame
schiappa ou autres insultes de la part
de nombreux policiers sur les réseaux
sociaux ou autres ce qu'on appelle troll
aujourd'hui c'est très très compliqué à
vivre c'est ce que je subis depuis deux
ans au même titre que beaucoup de
personnes au sein du mouvement et qui
ont été épargnés c'est ce qui est le
plus dégueulasse
au final de s'en prendre à quelqu'un
alors qu'on soit d'accord ou pas avec
rodrigues qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
avec les gilet jaune c'est servir de
l'infirmité d'une personne pour pouvoir
le le lui nuire
je vous cache pas les menaces de mort
que je peux recevoir tous les jours ça
commence un petit peu affaires à faire
lourd quoi psychologiquement parlant
alors les deux policiers en tout cas
sont sous contrôle judiciaire
aujourd'hui mise en examen on le disait
s'est responsabilisé erté pardon du
policier se sont pas les responsabilités
du donneur d'ordre des donneurs d'ordre
c'est pas plutôt à eux que vous en
voulez aujourd'hui j'en veux quand même
quelque part aux policiers
dans l'absolu parce que je n'ai aucune
réponse à son acte avant de pouvoir
pardonner parce que tout être humain a
peut-être la capacité de pouvoir
pardonner tout en essayant d'avoir une
explication à son geste
aujourd'hui ce qui est regrettable c'est
que dans l'histoire vous avez quatre
victimes parce que vous avez aussi mon
ami michael qui s'est pris qui s'est
pris une balle au niveau du tibia qui a
le tibia sacrément sacrément blessés
vous avez aussi l'étau policier qui sont
victimes de la situation quelque part
victime responsable parce que c'est eux
qu'ils avaient les armes en main et qui
ont qui ont su mal les utiliser à mon
encontre c'est une certitude mais eux
vont payer
d'une certaine façon ils sont déjà en
train de le payer c'est à dire qu'ils
sont mises en examen je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas facile à
vivre leurs familles doivent le subir
aujourd'hui je sais ce que c'est je sais
ce que c'est enfin vous voyez ce genre
de contexte de justice de s'en prendre
plein la tronche et et de prendre
quelque chose comme ça dans sa vie de
payer de sa responsabilité
j'imagine que c'est pas facile pour eux
et c'est ça qui est dommageable
aujourd'hui parce que les vrais
responsables
aujourd'hui sont les donneurs d'ordre
monsieur delpech le le le préfet en
place à l'époque des faits monsieur
nunez qui a menti le soir des faits
monsieur castaner qui est aussi un
menteur et qui qui est aussi donneur
d'ordre et j'en passe pour monsieur
macron aussi désolant d'ordre sauf
qu'aujourd'hui ces personnes là sont des
super citoyen en france qui ne méritent
pas justice de par leurs fonctions ce
qui est complètement regrettable parce
qu'ils auraient dû être exemplaires
alors ils n'ont pas donné en tout cas je
n'ai pas la preuve exacte et précise
qu'il aurait donné l'ordre correspond me
tire dessus
mais en tout cas ils n'ont pas donné le
contente de pouvoir enlever ses armes au
sein des manifestations au vu des
désagréments qui peuvent infliger
physiquement à l'ensemble de
manifestants qui a rappelé que je suis
le 20e manifestants à être éborgné qu'il
y en a eu 20 avant moi que le premier
n'aurait jamais dû exister je rappelle
qu'il ya au moins cinq à six femmes qui
ont été les borniers il ya eu cette main
arrachée
on parle de là on parle de la mise en
examen des policiers concernant la
sphère rodrigues mais vous avez aussi
des examens des mises en examen qui ont
été mis qui ont été faites pour la faire
gwendal le roi qui est aussi un copain
qui a perdu un oeil à rennes
il est important de préciser que c'est
le parquet qui avait fait appel d'une
décision de
de non poursuite de judiciaire vis-à-vis
du policier qui a épargné mon copain
voilà maintenant il est temps que la
justice se met en place pour l'ensemble
des manifestants parce que fait
important les 30 éborgné et 5 mutinés au
sein des manifestations n'ont jamais
étaient poursuivis pour violence sur sa
manifestation donc mérité quelque part
encore moins de se prendre une balle en
pleine tête
aujourd'hui il ya une loi qui fait débat
vous le savez le beauvau notamment de la
sécurité 1
est ce qu'il est nécessaire selon vous
pour établir les bons rapports entre la
population et la police mais
complètement
encore faudra-t-il que les citoyens
soient conviés à ce genre de réunion
il est facile aujourd'hui de faire une
réunion d'entre eux soient ses tripes
typiquement mac rognage en veut pour
preuve le grand débat à l'époque
voilà des petites réunions d'autres soit
c'est pas la première je pense depuis le
quinquennat enfin du moins du moins
depuis le début du quinquennat de du
président macron voilà donc on va les
laisser discuter de savoir comment mieux
éborgné et surtout de pouvoir
communiquer derrière pour pouvoir ne pas
être impliqué dans tout les mutilations
et toutes les horreurs qu'ils sont
capables de pratiquer en manifestation
je trouve regrettable aujourd'hui que
sur ce type de réunion les citoyens ne
soient pas convié de là je reviens à
leurs revendications une des
revendications gilet jaune qui est celle
d'avoir d'avoir une démocratie directe
et participative
on en veut pour preuve que même pas un
mutilé même pas un simple citoyen puisse
se trouver à ce type de réunion pour ne
serait-ce que de donner de la voix
et justement essayer d'améliorer le
quotidien à la fois des policiers et des
citoyens parce que je le rappelle
aujourd'hui moi j'ai un problème avec
les policiers qui sont censés maintenir
l'ordre au sein des manifestations et
non pas la police du quotidien ce qu'on
appelle les gardiens de la paix qui sont
malgré tout utile à la population parce
que quand il nous arrive en demi on est
bien content de les trouver malgré tout
la france a été épinglée un jérôme rudin
l'aise par an
un port 1 2i économistes comme une
démocratie défaillante en 2020 alors
c'est vrai que si on va dans le détail
de cette étude on parle des restrictions
dues à la crise sanitaire mais enfin
c'est un constat que vous vous partagez
la france est devenue une démocratie
défaillante challans vous écoutez ça
fait deux ans qu'on le crie haut et fort
vos équipes ont l'habitude de nous
suivrons manifestations cela fait partie
de notre principale revendication vous
savez la deuxième série de lois
liberticides que veut mettre en place ma
croquis faits pour faire référence à
l'article 24 qui fait partie des
articles qui font le plus de 2 de
polémiques faut savoir que le gilet
jaune n'en sont pas à leurs premières
lois liberticides aujourd'hui on vit
dans un paradoxe nous il est jaune c'est
qu'on a été interdit il ya un an et demi
deux ans de porter un masque au sein des
manifestations pour ne pas subir les gaz
et aujourd'hui on nous oblige à mettre
un masque
donc vous savez les lois liberticides
quelque part on est responsable nous
gilet jaune mais on en est victime aussi
depuis depuis maintenant deux ans de par
les arrestations arbitraires de pas de
comment on est traité au sein des
manifestations vous rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui on a simplement essayé de
me faire taire on me crevant à l'oeil
donc ça si c'est pas une entrave à la
démocratie mais est le plus le plus
abject dans cette histoire c'est que
vous avez un président mâcon qui se
permet de donner des leçons de
démocratie à d'autres pays qui mérite
sûrement d'avoir des leçons mais
lui-même fait pire encore oui il ya
certains opposants politiques qui se
retrouve en prison aujourd'hui dans le
monde - ma prison je la porte
aujourd'hui chaque matin que dieu fasse
donc les rapports aujourd'hui qu'il soit
de d'amnesty comme le dernier qui a été
sortie face aux arrestations arbitraires
de zircone hommiste face au manque de
démocratie aujourd'hui en france face à
ado ado au rapport de l'onu si vous vous
souvenez ou même certains ministres et
députés de la lru m
on dansait ne sachant même pas de qui il
parlait alors vous avez vu le
gouvernement aujourd'hui vous avez eu le
président fin de non-recevoir je veux
dire ça glisse comme sur l'eau et
continuera de mener des exactions au
sein des manifestations pour justement
faire taire l'ensemble des constats des
contestataires
aujourd'hui il ya une grande partie de
la france qui souffre peut-être encore
davantage qu'avant avec une perte de
revenus conséquente dans beaucoup de
secteurs avec la crise du coc vide
est-ce que 2022 va être pour vous le
grand retour des gilet jaune une fois la
crise sanitaire passé après stéphanie je
tiens à le rappeler les gilet jaune ce
n'est pas une idéologie le gilet jaune
c'est une métaphore c'est de pouvoir
mettre un gilet jaune
enfin du moins un gilet fluorescent
parce que aujourd'hui la majeure partie
des français qui construisent qui
travaillent qui sut qui donnent leur
sang qui donnent leur vie à la france
pau pour pouvoir travailler de de
pouvoir refaire redorer la france sont
invisibles
elle est là la métaphore vous avez un
mouvement populaire à partisans mais qui
est un melting-pot de l'ensemble des
français aujourd'hui vous avez toutes
les générations confondues toutes les
religions confondues tous les métiers
confondus tous les corps de métiers
confondus
au sein de cette manifestation et
aujourd'hui il est important de le
préciser et qu'on finisse par l'entendre
que ce n'est pas ce ne sont pas des gens
à part
voyez on est des simples citoyens qui
travaillent qui subissons aujourd'hui
les restrictions sanitaires du coc vide
au même titre que n'importe qui pour moi
un gilet jaune aujourd'hui peut être un
simple restaurateurs fatigués de la
situation fatigués de ne pas pouvoir
travailler de ne pas pouvoir gagner sa
vie au même titre que les petits
commerçants qui aujourd'hui souffrent de
la situation au même titre que les
stations de ski que ce que feint que
tous les métiers et tous les travaux
aujourd'hui en france qui sont impactés
par ces par ces mesures
son gilet jaune à partir du moment où on
n'est pas content et qu'on va à
l'encontre d'une décision du
vernement il faut aujourd'hui arrêter de
faire l'amalgamme avec toutes les
saloperies qu'on a pu entendre sur
différents médias attention je ne parle
pas de rtl que le devenir s'intéresser à
ces gens là assez gilet jaune qui
travaillent dans l'ombre pour pouvoir
proposer pour pouvoir revendiquer
apporter des solutions pour permettre un
mieux vivre aux français des groupes de
pensée sur la démocratie directe
participative qu'elle prenne le chemin
du rich ou pas que de se concentrer sur
des phénomènes de violence qui sont des
effets de loupe médiatique sur des
manifestations je vous garantis que le
mouvement est bien plus haut qu'il n'est
décrit dans les médias et que il gagne à
être connu et qu'on puisse s'intéresser
aux gens vous savez aujourd'hui on vit
dans une société où on est complètement
dépersonnaliser le simple fait d'arriver
en manifestation de demander le prénom à
quelqu'un de savoir ce qu'il fait dans
la vie est de savoir pourquoi il est là
la personne quand elle vous parle ça lui
fait du bien
il faut aujourd'hui qu'on puisse se
reconnaître qu'on ait quelque chose de
beaucoup plus humain vous pour espérer
une vie meilleure vous savez je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la france mérite mieux
que d'enchaîner les éborgné elle a une
histoire ce pays a une histoire allait
quand même la mère patrie des droits de
l'homme
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on devrait
s'inquiéter parce que le constat et les
suivants il est plus difficile de gagner
des libertés que d'en perdre merci
beaucoup jérôme heures andries d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
merci à vous la crise sanitaire à
présent olivier verrons a donc pris la
parole ce soir lors du point presse
hebdomadaire sur l'évolution de
l'épidémie le ministre de la santé qui
se félicite de chaque jour gagner sans
être confinés dans cette bataille contre
le coc vide et ces variants et précision
de nadège abderrazak olivier ferrand
s'est montré inquiet de la poussée des
variants britannique un sud africain et
brésilien sur le territoire et des
variants que le ministre de la santé
mettre plus contagieux les plus
dangereux que la forme initiale ce qui
concerne le fabricant britannique il a
été repéré dans 20 des cas 30 à midi le
fax en serait très efficace selon elle
est vive et rencontres se mariant
britannique
en revanche le doute persiste en ce qui
concerne les variants sud africain et
brésilien qui pour leur part sont
présents dans 4 à 5% à des cas de
contamination quotidien des variants qui
augmenterait les risques de réinfection
chez des patients déjà contaminé par le
cos vide
olivier vers ans est aussi lent dit
satisfait de la stratégie française de
lutte contre la propagation du coin 8 19
stratégie en opposition avec celle de
nos voisins européens notamment ce qui
concerne le confinement nos voisins ont
confiné parce qu'il n'avait plus le
choix
l'allemagne et l'angleterre ont connu
des journées avec plus de 1500 morts par
jour et donc il n'avait pas d'autre
alternative que celle d'un confinement
généralisée parce qu'il risquait une
saturation de leurs hôpitaux
c'est le cas aussi aux pays bas en
irlande en autriche et dans de nombreux
pays
olivier verrey toutefois qu'ils étaient
de la situation en moselle dans ce
territoire du grand test près de 300 cas
de contamination au carillon brésilien
et sud africaines ont été diagnostiqués
au cours des quatre derniers jours
et tellement qui est temps que le
ministre de la santé a décidé de se
déplacer sur place dès demain
la situation est un peu différente dans
un département du territoire c'est la
moselle
c'est une situation plus inquiétante
nous avons identifié dans ce département
plus de 300 cas de mutation évocatrice
des vins blancs sud africains et
brésiliens ces quatre derniers jours je
me rendrai demain en moselle pour
évaluer sur place la situation et
échanger avec les élus du territoire
j mènerait une concertation afin
d'anticiper les réponses qu'il nous
faudra trouver collectivement
un peu plus tôt dans la journée olivier
ferrand s'est rendu dans une école du
xiiie arrondissement de paris en
compagnie de jean castex le premier
ministre le but de cette visite ils
déployer une nouvelle arme de lutte
contre le rotavirus le test salivaire
par crachat à la rentrée des vacances
d'hiver le gouvernement espère que deux
à trois cents mille tests salivaires
pour être effectués chaque semaine dans
les écoles et on écoute jean castex ces
tests salivaires évidemment chacun a
connu le test naso pharyngé et ses
inconvénients
le test salivaire évidemment beaucoup
plus facile d'accès il permet là aussi
d'avoir des résultats dans des délais
rapides 24 heures puisque c'est la
technique pcr pour être extrêmement
précis et donc nous avons décidé de le
déployer d'abord on le comprend bien en
direction des enfants dans les écoles
dans les collèges dans les lycées parce
qu'évidemment c'est un public qui est
plus fragile et qui est parfois plus
réticents aux tests naso pharyngé et aux
désagréments qu'il peut provoquer
une école parisienne à laquelle n'a pas
participé jean michel blanquer
le ministre de l'éducation nationale a
été retenu à l'assemblée nationale où
les débats sur le projet de loi
séparatisme et alors que l'efficacité du
vaccin d'astrazeneca est régulièrement
remis en doute hier à genève le groupe
d'experts de l'om s a décidé de faire
taire les critiques on peut bien des
directives qui recommandent son usage
pour toutes les populations tous âges et
même face aux variants grazailles à un
vaccin envers et contre tous
pas de limite d'âge et une efficacité à
l'épreuve de tous les variants il
s'agirait là des performances du vaccin
astrazeneca produit par le laboratoire
britannique et d'une université d'oxford
selon l'organisation mondiale de la
santé humaine
même s'il ya une possible réduction du
plein impact de ce vaccin dans sa
capacité de protection et en particulier
contre les formes graves de la maladie
il n'y a aucune raison de ne pas
recommander son utilisation elle détient
même dans les pays où circulent de
variants le groupe d'experts a
recommandé que le vaccin soit administré
en deux doses avec huit à douze semaines
d'intervalle pour une meilleure réponse
immunitaire mais pour de nombreux pays
l'heure n'est pas à la confiance
le gouvernement sud africain envisage
même la revente des doses du vaccin
astrazeneca en sa possession jugé
efficace à seulement 57% contre le
variant le cas du virus suite à des
tests sur 6500 personnes en afrique du
sud le pays se tournent désormais vers
le vaccin johnson and johnson comme vu
les résultats des études efficacité le
ministère de l'assemblee pour vivre à la
phase de la vaccination prévue sur un
site dont les travailleurs de la santé
avec le vaccin de johnson and johnson a
évolué du raisin d'astrazeneca
le vaccin johnson & johnson s'est avéré
efficace contre le variant les
procédures d'approbation nécessaire pour
son utilisation en a vu son cours aux
usa
de son côté l'union européenne qui avait
été un peu optimiste sur sa campagne de
vaccination
on veut absolument muscler sa production
de vaccins en anticipant davantage la
gamme is made in need for speed la lutte
contre le virus et sa marathon ils ont
un sprint elle nécessite de la
prévoyance de l'endurance et de la
résistance
presque chaque jour nous entendons
parler de différentes variantes et de
leur contagiosité
nous n'avons pas encore une vue
d'ensemble de l'efficacité des
traitements et des vaccins sur les
nouvelles souches mais nous savons que
ces variantes continueront à apparaître
et nous savons que nous devons anticiper
et nous préparer immédiatement un druide
ou non à winston churchill un prix
pierre immédiat avec cinq semaines de
retard le problème de la campagne de
vaccination n'est pas seulement
sanitaire mais également économique
il représenterait 2 points des pib
perdus soit près de 90 milliards d'euros
selon les calculs de l'assureur allianz
mais côté laboratoire c'est le contraire
astrazeneca a annoncé ce jeudi avoir
plus que doublé son bénéfice net part en
2020 avec 3,2 milliards de dollars et 9
% de ventes supplémentaires l'agencé
européenne du médicament pour sa part
reste dubitative et demande à tous les
développeurs de vaccins d'évaluer
l'efficacité de leurs produits contre
les nouvelles mutations du coronavirus
ce sont déjà près de 151 millions de
doses qui ont été administrées dans le
monde
un espoir pour de nombreux états faso
2,36 millions de morts qui a déjà causé
la pandémie restez avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de
sanofi pas de vaccin contre le coc vide
mais
un dividende en hausse l'annnonce de
sanofi de verser plus de 4 milliards
d'euros à ses actionnaires alors qu'ils
suppriment des emplois notamment dans la
recherche suscite la polémique
et puis nous évoquerons l'italie le
mouvement 5 étoiles s'est prononcé en
faveur du gouvernement d'unité nationale
dirigé par mario draghi
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française d'autres affirment
même que nous ne sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même un
certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre balle aux politiques et les
experts et même les citoyens on est une
société qui est totalement percuté et on
ne peut pas considérer une démocratie
vit véritablement une amplitude de ses
possibles énorme et une de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment qu'on repart
à zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité
c'est le sentiment d'exister
d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde y la
pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
avec le climat ou encore la crise
sanitaire la crise économique est l'un
des principaux défis qui attendent joe
biden nous avons plus de 20 millions de
personnes qui perçoivent des indemnités
de chômage maintenant le plan de
monsieur biden ne remet pas les gens au
travail
soit vous avez extinction de la
croissance totalement ou alors vous
laisser filer la monnaie et tout d'un
coup vous allez vous retrouver comme au
venezuela ou ailleurs nous avons besoin
d'une reconstruction économique massive
et ni monsieur trump ni monsieur byden
ne semble capable
désireux de le faire c'est la même
politique avec la même avec la même
vision des choses c'est à dire
l'amérique d'abord
[Musique]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise lorsque c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait ça au sérieux nos métiers il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris après
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier à
quelles conditions pires gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restaurants
c'est pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille je sais c'est de faire au
mieux c'est aussi tout en questionnant
sur la société sur le rapport à la
solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois s'il faut un
évidemment
[Musique]
oh
21h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez sanofi qui
a donc déjà annoncé des suppressions de
postes en france s'apprête également à
quitter le bangladesh le géant
pharmaceutique vient de céder un peu
plus de la moitié de ses parts et aurait
refusé de verser une prime de cession à
ses employés selon l'un des syndicats du
personnel
en conséquence les salariés ont depuis
samedi décidé de se mettre en grève de
la faim une situation dénoncée par le
député de la france a soumis françois
ruffin coûté depuis samedi les salariés
de sanofi au bangladesh sont en grève de
la faim
la multinationale quittent le pays et
les laisse complètement à poil
sanofi aucun vaccin mais des kilos de
ventes à l'exportation mais ça ne fait
toujours pas de vaccin contre locaux
vides mais un dividende en hausse
l'annnonce du géant pharmaceutique de
verser plus de 4 milliards d'euros à ses
actionnaires alors et qu'ils suppriment
des emplois notamment dans la recherche
ce site bien évidemment la polémique
une générosité que le groupe justifie
par de bons résultats et par un contexte
très concurrentiel qui l'obligent à
rester attractif mais cette hausse de
dividende en pleine crise sanitaire est
elle aussi scandaleuses qu'elles n'y
paraissent est l'objet de l'élite aux
échos ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques sapir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france soir
c'est fini alors jacques y at il
réellement une affaire sanofi alors oui
on peut le penser à première vue
effectivement sanofi a des gros
problèmes avec la mise au point de son
vaccin sanofi vient de supprimer 1700
postes dont 400 dans la recherche et
dans le même temps sanofi augmente son
dividende donc on peut penser qu'
effectivement un scandale maintenant il
faut quand même voir que cette
augmentation de dividende
elle n'est pas très importante on était
à 3 euros 15 en 2019 on sera à 3 euros
20 en 2020
il faut aussi savoir que cette
augmentation de dividende
elle correspond à une augmentation des
profits mais dû à la revente d'une
société qui appartenait à sanofi la
société régénérant celle qui avait fait
le traitement à base d'anticorps qui a
été donnée à donald train donc on peut
se poser quand même la question suivante
qui est de savoir est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
un vrai scandale mais ce scandale est ce
que ça ne serait pas beaucoup plus dans
la stratégie qu'a suivi sanofi depuis
ces dernières années
ainsi jane vous nous dites que la hausse
du dividende est faible dans quelle
mesure alors si vous voulez comme je
vous le dis les dividendes ils sont
passés 2,3 euros 15 en 2010 9 à 3 euros
vin c'est pas énorme
par contre maintenant si on regarde
l'évolution des dividendes depuis 2000
cas on voit qu'ils ont beaucoup monté de
2004 à 2007 2009 ils ont augmenté de
plus de 50% et qu'ils recommencent à
augmenter de manière assez sensible
depuis 2016 2017
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que sanofi est une société qui fait
gagner de l'argent à ses actionnaires
c'est très bien mais quand elle fait
gagner de l'argent à ce niveau là et
dans ces proportions là il ya ça veut
dire que sanofi elle fait passé moi
l'expression cracher du cash
autrement dit elle sert les coûts
partout où c'est possible
elle ne développe que les activités qui
sont le plus profitable
un autre élément à prendre aussi en
compte c'est la valeur de l'action le
cours de l'action la capitalisation
or là aussi on voit qu'il ya une forte
augmentation
une augmentation de plus de 40 % de 2004
à 2020 et même si on prend simplement
l'augmentation jusqu'à fin 2019 s'est
pratiquement 50% donc là aussi il y a un
très gros problème et on peut penser que
c'est l'ensemble du modèle de sanofi qui
est aujourd'hui en cause alors jacques à
cette hausse du dividende n'est pas un
problème en substance c'est pas
exactement ce que j'ai dit saoulé quand
il ya des dividendes
c'est qu'il ya des profits alors il
faudrait voir à quoi correspondent les
profits pour 2020 on sait que pour 2018
et 2019
les chiffres qui s'affiche sur l'écran
sont ceux des comptes de sanofi bas on
voit très bien quel a été le chiffre
d'affaires de cette entreprise on voit
que c'est un chiffre d'affaires qui
tourne autour de 71 % pour les
médicaments d'entre 15 et 16% pour ce
qui est des vaccins et 13% à peu près
pour ce qui est des produits de santé
autrement dit des choses qui seraient
qui relève plutôt de la parapharmacie
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé en 2001
mais en 2020 la société a comme je les
dis revendu une filiale régénérant qui
est une filiale qui a réalisé un très
beau coup parce que c'est elle qui a mis
au point justement ce traitement contre
le co lead qui a été acheté en
particulier par l'allemagne ce
traitement à base d'anticorps
alors on peut se poser la même question
si vous voulez on voit bien que le
profit de 2020 n'est pas durable cette
histoire de vendre une société sanofi ne
pourra pas le recommencer toutes les
années c'est un fusil à un coup
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait des profits
est ce qu'on doit nécessairement les
distribuer aux actionnaires ou justement
parce que sanofi rencontrent des
problèmes industriels dans la mise au
point de son vaccin des problèmes dont
on espère qu'ils seront résolus mais est
ce qu'il ne faudrait pas
de mettre de l'argent pour la recherche
ou provisionné d'une certaine manière se
constituer un matelas pour des années
plus difficiles
donc là il ya déjà un premier problème
au niveau de la stratégie de sanofi
alors jacques qui sont ses actionnaires
alors c'est extrêmement intéressant
en fait si on regarde fonctionnellement
on voit que pratiquement 80 % de
l'actionnariat de sanofi dépend de ce
qu'on appelle des investisseurs
institutionnels que ces investisseurs
institutionnels soit étranger ils
représentent environ 60% ou qu'ils
soient français ils représentent environ
16% te fais l'actionnariat après c'est
essentiellement une grande entreprise
française même si elle est gérée par un
américain l'oréal et puis il y à des
particuliers on voit d'ailleurs que les
salariés ne représentent que 7%
sur ce total ça c'est je dirais une
analyse fonctionnelle
après si on regarde par pays c'est aussi
très intéressant on dit beaucoup que
sanofi est une entreprise française
mais enfin les actionnaires français ne
représente que 36% du capital le reste
de l'europe représente environ 27 % les
etats-unis 35% et là dedans il y a en
particulier le fonds blackrock
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que sanofi c'est une société qui
s'est très largement financiarisé et qui
s'est globalisée depuis grosso modo le
début des années 2000 cette société
n'est absolument pas le champion
français que l'on nous décrit elle n'a
plus grand-chose de française en réalité
alors messi sanofi va effectivement
supprimer un dea en point jacques ne
va-t-il pas en créer d'autres avec la
sous traitance pour le vaccin de pfizer
comme il l'a d'ailleurs proposé oui
effectivement il y à cet accord de sous
traitance qui a été passé avec pfizer
maintenant ses effets sur l'emploi
sanofi ou sur la capacité technologique
de sanofi seront extrêmement limité
parce qu'il faut quand même le dire
c'est un accord avec pfizer qui portent
uniquement sur le flaconnage autrement
dit sur l'emballage du vaccin sanofi va
recevoir en fait le produit
et puis va se contenter de le mettre
dans des petites bouteilles dans ces
petits flacons qui contiennent
maintenant si dose dit on bon c'est pas
quand même extrêmement glorieux
techniquement et pourquoi alors pourquoi
ben voilà c'est juste un problème c'est
uniquement de la sous traitance et de la
sous-traitance qui est très très très
peu intéressante
il y avait pourtant une autre voie qui
était possible quand sanofi a commencé à
comprendre que la mise au point de son
vaccin durer plus longtemps que ce qui
était prévu
et ça ça date en fait de la fin de
l'année et bien
sanofi aurait peu cherché à rentrer en
contact avec par exemple des autres
producteurs de vaccins pour obtenir des
licences
prenons le cas de spoutnik v de
l'institut gamaleya le gouvernement
français est informé en réalité de la
capacité et des effets de spoutnik v
depuis grosso modo le mois de décembre
c'est là où il ya une mission d' enquête
qui a été envoyé par le gouvernement
français à l'institut gamaleya
astrazeneca a immédiatement décidé de
rentrer dans un accord avec l'institut
gamaleya pourquoi est-ce que sanofi ne
l'a pas fait pourquoi est-ce que sanofi
n'a pas cherché justement à obtenir
cette licence
car même si la production de vaccins ne
pourrait commencer que fin juin ou en
juillet en supposant que le vaccin soit
homologué à la fin du mois de février ou
au début du mois de mars
malgré tout cela apporterait une
contribution extrêmement importante
au programme vaccinal français parce
qu'il faut rapport il faut rappeler que
spoutnik v c'est un vaccin qui est
quasiment aussi efficace que pfizer
et c'est un vaccin qui est beaucoup plus
simple d'emploi qui ne demandent pas du
tout les mêmes précautions au niveau de
la chaîne de transport et de la chaîne
logistique
par ailleurs une cession de licences
c'est quand même autrement plus
intéressant que de faire du flaconnage
alors jacques finalement les dividendes
de sanofi en rien notre première
question scandale ou non eh bien je
dirais que healy à certains scandales
avec sanofi mais qu'il n'est pas
nécessairement là où on le croit il
n'est pas nécessairement sur la question
des dividendes
oui effectivement sanofi va distribuer
des dividendes mais ce n'est pas une
augmentation qui est si importante que
cela le véritable scandale
c'est plutôt l'évolution générale de
cette société depuis maintenant au moins
une quinzaine d'années une société qui
sait financiarisé qui s'est globalisée
et qui est maintenant dans une logique
du profit immédiat du profit à très
court terme ce qui l'a amené à préférer
rentrer dans une logique de sous
traitance de flaconnage pour un grand
groupe américain pfizer
plutôt que de tenter de décrocher la
licence pour un vilain véritable vaccin
avec l'institut gamaleya en russie merci
jacques en tout cas pour ce point de vue
plutôt inédit merci à vous et à la
semaine prochaine
en italie feu vert pour mario draghi les
militants du mouvement 5 étoiles ont ce
jeudi voter pour que leur parti
rejoignent le futur gouvernement de l'ex
président de la banque centrale
européenne l'enjeu désormais former une
coalition après la démission de choses
étaient comptés et nicolas petit le
résultat était particulièrement attendue
les militants du mouvement 5 étoiles
avait ce jeudi la balle dans leur camp
pour décider s'ils devaient ou non
apporté leur soutien à mario draghi et
peser sur le sort du pays lors du vote
en ligne
ils se sont prononcés pour le ralliement
du parti à 59,3 % des voix une décision
saluée par l'une des figures de proue du
mouvement
luigi di maio la responsabilité le prix
de la grandeur aujourd'hui nos membres
ont une fois de plus fait preuve d'une
grande maturité de loyauté envers les
institutions et d'un sentiment
d'appartenance au pays
dans l'un des moments les plus
dramatiques de notre histoire récente le
mouvement 5 étoiles choisi la voie du
courage et de la participation
mais surtout choisi la voie européenne
choisit un ensemble de valeurs et de
droit dont nous bénéficions tous au
quotidien et derrière lesquels se cache
malheureusement souvent l'égoïsme et le
personnalisme avec ce ralliement un
mario draghi rassemble une large
majorité avant le mouvement 5 étoiles
qui représente un tiers des élus au
parlement
il avait déjà reçu des soutiens de poids
notamment celui du leader de la ligue du
nord matteo salvini ou encore de l'ex
président du conseil silvio berlusconi
chef du parti forza italia mais fallait
mans annonce très pâle fait nous
jouerons notre rôle de manière loyale et
constructive
la gravité du moment exige que chacun
mette de côté les calculs les tactiques
et les intérêts électoraux pour faire
passer le salut du pays avant tout il se
tait ses intérêts chez électorat ali si
cela se produit je suis certain que
l'italie pourra à nouveau se relever et
aller de l'avant
c'est quoi il se verra son chef toqué
les tailles
le ch l'a un peu plus de quinze jours
après la démission du président du
conseil giuseppe compter
l'italie semble désormais en bonne voie
mais le chantier ne fait que commencer
mario draghi pourrait annoncer la
composition de son gouvernement
dès la fin de semaine et demander un
vote de confiance au parlement quasiment
dans la foulée le temps presse car la
plupart des mesures de lutte contre
l'épidémie de covile 19 expire ce lundi
pour prolonger l'interdiction de se
déplacer entre les régions ou encore le
couvre-feu un nouveau décret est
nécessaire de l'autre côté des alpes
la pandémie a fait plus de 92 mille
morts et pour en parler nous sommes en
direct depuis rome avec massimo nava
éditorialiste au corriere della serra
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir massimo nava merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france donc 59,3 % des
votants se sont prononcés ce soir en
faveur d'un soutien au gouvernement
draghi est ce que cela vous étonne le
mouvement 5 étoiles poutine sortir
affaibli de ce choix est maintenant
renzi en ressort au contraire grandit
pas écouté et sous les futurs des
matériaux rinne si c'est vraiment un
pari très très difficile à dire parce
que c'est un jeu de poker et pour
l'amour est réussie parce qu'elle sait
lui a fait qu'il ya un peu ouvert la rue
pour une nouvelle gouvernement avec
mario draghi
ce qui concerne les 5 étoiles il ya un
peu des termes d'émissions pas ce que
fait les mouvements c'est très déchiré
et la majorité c'est très faible parce
qu'elle soit 100% des votantes pour un
mouvement où la participation était de
presque 70 mille votants tu sais pas
c'est pas ces problématiques d'ordre
d'un moment très uni évidemment les
bêtes et gris look est à présent l'homme
un argument des silences et a décidé dé
reprendre un peu la main d'oeuvre de
mouvement a choisi évidemment bonne à
changer un peu la donne mais ya rien d
des détentions dans l'intérieur à très
fort parce que vous savez les mouvements
cette étoile est née contre la classe
des les gens contre les banques contre
même la personnalité des mario draghi se
changeait tout c'est franchement très
difficile mais en ce moment on assiste à
un vrai dramatique je vous avais dit
machiavélique gérard et aux italiens
typiquement italienne mais avec un
résultat pour le moment spectaculaire
c'est à dire la personnalité plus
important plus estimé plus considérés
dans la dans l'europe dans l'italie est
de même au niveau international
aujourd'hui c'est lécher les prochaines
leur chef de go
un caviar avec en large majorité qui
comprendra aussi la gauche partie de la
droite et les mouvements 5 étoiles et en
plus à ces sorties un peu un miracle et
zi he et un miracle si dès maintenant
samedi le leader dé la lega nord de
l'année globale c'est à dire la droite
nationaliste un peu un peu un outil
européenne qui a choisi de participer à
cette gouvernement et donc c'est vrai
qu'étant tous les effets de l'appareil
ni délai de l'émergence économique les
problèmes qui l'italie est aussi le pays
d'europe qui a vraiment changé la dent
est faussé tous les partis politiques à
mettre de côté leurs intérêts personnels
l excès de la politique politicienne
pour un tour un projet que tu veux plus
que d'une plus longue et un ampleur
importante en plus quant au
contournement seiler l'italie c'est les
pays qui ont plus profité des airs et
commerçants c'est à dire puisque 200
milliards d'euros qui sont créés à
d'arriver à donc être versée à l'italie
sous forme est sous tension était prête
et évidemment il faut avoir des plongées
très concrètes pour bien un dépenser cet
argent est évidemment dans les mains des
mario draghi tout le monde se sent
beaucoup plus sûr alors mario draghi
c'est l'homme de la bce c'est bâle a
connu pour être un technocrate est ce
que c'est la victoire ce soir d'un
retour d es libre retour de la
technocratie en italie non parce que à
mon avis c'est le personnage c'est
beaucoup différent des mario monti si
vous pensez à les allées précédente
disons gouvernement technocratique
d'abord parce que mario draghi s'est
aussi je dirais pas que politicienne
mais ils viennent des roms à lang
expérience
à la banque italienne à la max est un
rite aliens et s'auto à la banque
européenne à 1 min andré politiques et
monétaires et social et tout le monde
connaît qui avait des relations très
stricte avec un gala merck est donc je
pense que on peut pas considérer
simplement marie granier commun notre
actionnaire votation pour vous à
pourvoir remonter justement redresser la
situation s'est vraiment l'homme de la
situation
absolument parce qu'en plus d'abord les
soutiennent des phases politique comme
je disais payeurs mais aussi il va aussi
à former un gouvernement qui y en a des
techniciennes des personnalités des
séquences de sa confiance mais aussi des
politiques des hommes politiques qui
représente un peu le tout les panoramas
et politique il a déjà annoncé un chose
de très important
c'est à dire un grand ministère pour la
transition écologique un peu sous le
modèle français qui avait fait sarkozy
après est aussi hollande à l'époque
et tant qu un grand ministère qui qui
qui comprend différents fonctionne à
l'infrastructure l'écologie la
transition énergétique et tout ça et ça
s'en plaignait un premier résultat est
bon on verra après la formation l'équipe
que cela a lancé je pense de membres
près de mains [ __ ] est donc un bus à
souligner aussi que mario draghi a fait
tomber les spread et déjà les jours qui
était qui en proposait lou ye au
gouvernement presque un milliard d'euros
d'intérêts que l'italie aa et panne il
justement pour simplement avec l'annoncé
sonore et donc c'est tout le monde est
content des sa et dans les sondages un
peu c'est vraiment transversale à tous
les phases politique la satisfation deux
pour un
pour comme sa nomination mme simon on
imagine qu'à une urgence comme dans tous
les pays quasiment du monde
malheureusement la crise sanitaire
peut-être et la campagne de vaccination
est ce qu'on fait confiance en
l'expertisé de mario draghi
sur ce point parce qu'il va alors c'est
vous savez sur la campagne de
vaccination en fait les gouvernements
précédents de monsieur co qui a bien
travaillé et l'italie avaient beaucoup
plus des vaccinations que la france pour
l'équipe par exemple est un fait il ya
un peu des défiance entre les gens et en
des propositions de mario draghi à ce
moment des dérangerait la coordination
de la distribution de face à haut niveau
puis centralisée pas ce qu'est un pl est
un plus vous serez les italiennes
bailly prestige général avec beaucoup d
aimé pouvoir local régional et donc il
ya toujours des conflits sous entre les
régions des gouvernements central et ça
je pense que mario draghi la terminer
cette mettre fin à cette contrainte
intel tattoo ces polémiques sont sortis
et qui ont en fait même de nager
beaucoup la la la situation n'en crée
des problèmes qui pouvaient être est
beaucoup plus facile à résoudre et avec
un vision c'est alizé l'émergence
sanitaires merci massimo nava je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialiste au
corriere della serra merci d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france et
c'est la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve dans quelques petites minutes
pour faire un point complet sur
l'actualité du jour
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]